let's say you wanted to buy this Primark
t-shirt if you're shopping on primark's
website you'll quickly discover that you
can't
over the past 10 years e-commerce sales
have more than doubled but last year
European fast fashion retailer Primark
made 9.5 billion in sales revenue
without a single penny from online
shopping
we made a very clear choice and our
Clear Choice is bricks and mortar this
comes at an uncertain time for
struggling clothing retailers retailers
like Forever 21 JCPenney and Neiman
Marcus have closed stores and filed for
bankruptcy and while a UBS report shows
up to 80 000 retail stores will close in
the next five years Primark plans to
expand to 60 stores in the same time
frame is driving two hours from Toronto
to Buffalo to shop at Primark worth it
heck yes I used to fly six hours to do
so so how is Primark expanding without
online shopping
this is the economics of Primark fashion
retailer is is incredibly competitive
more so than ever there's not many
players especially in fast fashion that
are making fat margins pretty much the
thinking everywhere is that you have to
have this online presence but online
shopping is actually actually incredibly
expensive for retailers you have to have
a logistical hub from which you would
dispatch the goods and then you'd
probably have a local distribution
center from which you have to do last
mile delivery each step of that just is
an extra layer of cost that just eats
away at the margin which in fashion is
very very slim anyway but the real
killer for e-commerce is that somebody
who buys something on the Internet is
far more likely to return that product
than somebody who goes into a store
returns are one of the biggest profit
losses for online retailers on average
processing a return for a hundred
dollars worth of merchandise bought
online costs a company 26.50 for years
online retailers just ate these expenses
only now are more of them deciding to
pass the cost back to the consumer
Primark have just stayed right from the
beginning we don't think we can make
money out of e-commerce we're not even
going to try we're going to focus all
our resources on the physical store and
protect our margins and that wasn't an
issue for the retailer until now Primark
is expected to close all 189 of its UK
stores tonight and it doesn't have an
online offering to fall back on
e-commerce was a Lifeline for a lot of
retailers during the pandemic they
couldn't open their stores where they
were still able to make some sales on
the internet but Primark didn't budge
even as consumers urged for it to offer
online shopping and even after its
Revenue dropped by almost 2 billion
pounds and I think their confidence in
this model of having no digital sales
and only using stores I think was
probably shaken by the pandemic who
knows what would have happened if it had
gone on for longer I think the closures
weren't quite long enough to really tip
the scales and force them to
fundamentally rethink the model instead
of traditional online shopping in 2022
Primark launched a trial service called
click and collect in select UK stores
customers can select certain products
online then pick up their orders in
store so Primark still has some cost to
maintain its website but it's cheaper
than running a true online shop
so Primark makes a sale but they don't
have any of the logistical costs that
would be involved in packing it up and
then shipping it out to your home and
there's another bonus for Primark since
the customer has to go inside to collect
their purchase they're likely to browse
around and maybe even buy more
they make the sale online but then they
have a good chance of making some extra
sales when that person visits them
consumer psychologists call this shop
actually once you've already decided to
make a dress it's easier to justify
adding more to your cart it always feels
just overwhelmingly busy with people who
are in there looking for bargains and
it's not just clothing Primark lures
consumers with beauty home and travel
products similar to a department store
what we like to say about Primark here
in the US is that you know we're all
treasure without the hunt so customers
may go in for a new t-shirt and leave
with a suitcase but a Primark that I can
drive to and don't have to fly to is a
dream because that means there is no
limit to what I can buy and bring home
to carry this vast selection of items
Primark finds large retail spaces
because it relies on selling a lot it's
one of the largest retailers in the UK
by volume and one of the largest across
all of Europe last year Primark made
about 9.5 billion in sales revenue in
part by selling a lot of things at low
profit margins and it does this by
sourcing a lot of its clothing from Asia
combined with not offering online
shopping this enables Primark to sell
its merchandise at lower prices even
lower than many other fast fashion
retailers where they do have serious
rivals on Price is with the digital only
players that like Sheen for example they
are often even cheaper than Primark but
according to the National Retail
Federation eighty percent of shopping
still happens in store giving Primark an
edge over its digital only competitors
even so its in-store shopping model got
off to a rocky start in the U.S Primark
opened its first U.S store in Boston
back in 2015. although it was already
popular in the UK its U.S expansion
started slowly over four years it opened
nine stores after years of
experimentation Primark learned it would
have to change to succeed in the U.S
when we first opened we took a similar
stall size that we would have had in
Europe but when Primark opened its
stores across the Northeast it struggled
to find the right store density what
they found in the US is that retail is
so much more competitive there's a lot
more retail in downtown
areas in the US and than there is in the
UK for example so you just can't support
a massive store it's just not possible
to get enough revenue for the size to
support its large store sizes it needed
a lot of foot traffic but unlike the UK
stores which were located in constantly
busy areas U.S stores were mostly in
malls where during the week foot traffic
dwindled we learned that actually 35
000 square foot of retail selling space
is is actually the The Sweet Spot for us
they didn't face the commercial pressure
that a publicly owned company might have
faced to suddenly open 100 stores and
and get really big really quickly and
then possibly risk disaster because they
hadn't thought it through the culture of
Primark has always been to take our time
and and to test and learn and we've done
that in every country where we've
introduced the brand this wasn't about
you know growing market share at all
costs and the overall retail Market is
Shifting online shopping hit a peak
during covid but now growth is beginning
to slow as people return to store I
think that's never been so important as
it is since we came out of covet I think
there has been a massive rediscovery of
being in malls being together physical
shopping and I think is a business that
took the decision a long time ago to
have that as our core strategy
um you know it has continued to allow us
to be successful foreign
[Music]